لطالما أحببت لوري لين أن تكون
نشطة ولكن في أواخر الخمسينيات من عمرها بدأت
تشعر بالتعب وتفتقر إلى الدافع للعمل وأصبحت
مفاصلها مؤلمة.  ظهر أيضًا ضباب في المخ والومضات الساخنة
تقول لين إنها كافحت
مع كل هذا لمدة عامين تقريبًا ، لكن الأمر كان له
تأثير سلبي على حياتها ، كل هذه
الأشياء تأتي إليك ، فقط أنت تعلم أنها
جعلتك تشعر بأنك لست شخصًا كاملًا
يقول لين اختبار الدم  كشفت أن
هرمون التستوستيرون الخاص بها كان منخفضًا مما جعلها
مرشحة لإجراء يتم إجراؤه في
أورلاندو هيلث حيث يتم إعطاء جرعة منخفضة من هرمون
التستوستيرون من خلال
بيليه يتم حقنها تحت الجلد أثناء
زيارة سريعة للمكتب ولكن مع مرور الوقت
أعتقد أنك  سنرى أن هذا
أصبح معيارًا زائفًا للرعاية والذي
سيكون خيارًا لجميع
المرضى تقريبًا لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكانهم تحسين
أعراض انقطاع الطمث هذه ، فإن
إجراء التستوستيرون بيليه لم تتم
الموافقة عليه حاليًا من قِبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ، لكن Pepe يقول
إنه يوفر الراحة للعديد من
مرضاه ويستمر  بين 12 و 16
أسبوعًا ، هناك القليل من المخاطر
وراء هرمون الاستروجين ، ولا يوجد خطر وراء هرمون
التستوستيرون ، لذا فهو هرمون آمن
نراقب مستوى الجرعات في حوالي أربعة
أسابيع للتأكد من أننا نبحث
عن النطاق المناسب الذي
تقول لين العلاجية أنها بدأت  رؤية
النتائج في غضون أيام وعادت إلى
الشعور بنفسها مرة أخرى ، أود أن أقول إنني
أعمل في جميع الأسطوانات للصحة
الدقيقة ، أنا ماندي غايثر